gunshots outside the presidential palace
overwhelmed police in the military
attempt to disperse a defiant crowd
calling on President Lee brainwork
Arcata
to step down I think that people coming
out today the youth the women young and
old shows that Molly's fed up we want to
change the system we want this regime to
leave we want a new social contract to
set up a Molly that stands up earlier
over 20,000 people gathered in
Independence Square in the capital
Bamako to listen to the influential
cleric Mohammed Eko once a close ally to
Keita he has become the government's
most outspoken critic it is time for
everything to change our army is
disorganized demoralized the money that
was promised to the army has been
diverted they are no longer receiving
their food rations we are the
laughingstock the whole region Keita was
reelected in 2018 on a promise to bring
peace in a country torn by armed groups
and ethnic violence in the last year
alone a million people have been
displaced and 4,000 have been killed
four million mullions are in need of
urgent humanitarian assistance 14,000 UN
peacekeepers are powerless to stop the
violence in the north and center the
state is present only in named police
elected officials teachers and health
workers are fleeing their posts
fearing attacks armed groups like the
Islamic state in the greater Sahara
al-qaeda affiliates and ethnic militias
fill the void and compete to control
these regions in an attempt to push them
out Malian forces and governed back
groups are accused of killing and
torturing civilians according to you an
investigation since January they've
committed more acts of extrajudicial
killings and human rights violations
than the armed groups that they're
fighting
many of these demonstrators have lost
faith in their security forces few came
out to vote in April's parliamentary
elections choosing instead to
demonstrate their discontent in Mali's
leader on the streets in a country
on the brink Nicolas Hawk al-jazeera